hi everyone good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you're
joining us um in the country uh my name
is roy and i'm here to give you a quick
overview of camp con
our new summer
camp
quick agenda here we're going to do
intros real quickly talk about camp con
the details kind of from the 30 000 foot
view all the way down to the ground
level view talk a little bit about these
new courses or get ready for grade level
courses and then have some time with
questions we're going to do all this in
about 30 minutes
first some intros i as i mentioned my
name is roy i am on the district
partnership team at khan academy i'm
joined by my colleague patti sullivan
panda she is also
on my teammate on the district
partnership team and patty's going to be
kind of moderating your questions and
we'll
reference them and go through them
during the q and a session
lauren quan is on our marketing team she
does a lot of our parent marketing so
it's great to have lauren here she's
also going to be monitoring questions so
feel free to type those in throughout
the next 15 minutes we'll get to them
either in the chat or as we do the q a a
little bit later and please note that
this webinar will be recorded and sent
to you after the session you'll also see
that there is a handout a one-pager that
just has some details on campcon right
on your um
go to webinar dashboard there it's
titled campcon article webinar
that's who we are
and we don't have time to uh do intros
for every single person in here but we
have been talking with and hearing from
parents throughout the school year
particularly in the spring what we heard
from them was this particular school
year was surprising it was unexpected it
was overwhelming it was hectic and
really it was just a lot
and recognizing all those things that
the school year was we want to first
thank you parents for being a caregiver
and a teacher
a coach for your children a juggler
really of all the different
responsibilities you have and really
just for being there for your family for
your children
and there's that in mind that we start
at camp con
which is our real first summer camp that
we're doing virtually of course and
we're trying to think of what could be a
way that we could prepare students for
math next year do some things that might
help to build their confidence and also
do it in a fun way that recognizes hey
it's still summer vacation even though
this
past school year was all
all these different things that we
didn't really expect
we want to make sure that
camp con does
prepare students for math and build the
confidence and also doing a way that's
kind of flexible for parents and for
children too
that's kind of like the 30 000 foot view
of what camp con is i'm going to just go
a little bit lower to say like the 15
000 foot view
give some details on camp con so camp
con runs from june 22nd this monday we
just launched you might have received an
email from us about it actually and
it'll go all the way to august 28th so a
total of 10 weeks
and it's intended for students entering
grades 3 through 12 this fall
and just like i mentioned before we want
to make this flexible for folks so
participants can join and stay whenever
and for however long and we also want to
make this accessible for everyone so
we've made sure that it's free for
everyone too
down below you'll see kind of our four
like stinky pinkies these are like our
mascot for um camp con
and here are the ingredients of camp con
so one
is the get ready for math courses get
ready for grade level courses these are
our math courses that we're going to go
into in a little bit more detail
in addition campcon is going to deliver
some strategies for real self-driven
learning so thinking about how children
students can really be kind of owners of
their own learning and really drive
their own learning and part we want to
make sure that you know
the parents aren't being asked to do too
much because we know you have done so
much throughout this school year
and then also like i mentioned we want
to make sure that camp con gives
suggestions for fun and motivational
things that you and your children can do
over the summer and we think we can
combine all those three things together
that's gonna lead to sustained learning
not just this summer but in years ahead
all right so how it works i'm gonna go a
little bit more detail now
i already mentioned this monday you all
should have received an email just
announcing camp con
and we sent that email to all our
parents in the u.s
all learners over the age of 13 and all
our us math teachers too
from now until august 28th over that
period of the next nine weeks we're
going to give weekly guidance where
learners can progress on those get ready
courses that we're going to go into
and receive some
weekly recommendations via email too
and included in that weekly guidance is
just some tips and opportunities to
really recognize and reflect on progress
giving some ideas for how you might
celebrate the
your children are putting in the
learnings that they might have
throughout the year and again making
sure we have some time for fun too
that's a real quick overview if you have
any additional questions i'm going to
refer you back to that one pager that's
in your handouts and this website on the
bottom here con.co
campcon 2020 and we're also on social
under the hashtag campcon 2020.
all right i mentioned the weekly
recommendations and suggestions that
we're sending out here's a rough outline
of what it looks like
each of our weekly emails will have five
suggestions along kind of three
different topics
before i get into that i want to mention
that all our messages are available in
spanish
and then those three topics are one
learning goals for your get ready for
grade level courses
second topic is learning tips and they
can be learning tips about how to use
khan academy how might you share
progress with a
teacher or with an adult
or some reflection prompts about how do
you best learn what are some things that
you really
um
like doing in a classroom
and then the third topic are these fun
and motivational activities and these
are going to be taken from our own
content library so for instance you know
one of the things that we're going to
suggest is our pixar in a box
content which is going to be a set of
courses and activities that students can
really
do to kind of hone in on their
imagination and then we're also going to
take some fun and motivational
activities from some of our partner
organizations too who have great ideas
for how do you spend the summer and how
do you spend the summer not just in
front of a screen but also outside and
with friends and with family
for each of these topics we're going to
have
clickable videos on various weeks where
you can just write directly in the email
view a video or go to a partner resource
now to get these emails there's no sign
up you'll need to do anything other than
have a khan academy account if you're a
parent
and will also be sending a similar but
slightly differently worded email to
learners
who have spent any time on our get ready
for math courses
all right i feel like i've been talking
up these um get ready for grade level
courses quite a bit and i want to spend
the next few minutes just highlighting
what those are
so our get ready for math courses
are
newly created math courses
they were created or curated in part
because we heard from parents we heard
from teachers who said hey what can we
do or what can our students or children
do between now and whenever school
reopens that's going to make sure that
they're ready to learn that they're
ready to hit the ground running when
school year 2021 begins
what we did was go back to all of our
previous or existing math courses and we
just pulled the content and the skills
that we think are most important for a
student to be successful in their math
class next year
so if you have a child going into fourth
grade for instance you would take the
get ready for fourth grade level course
and in that get ready for fourth grade
level course you're gonna see skills
that maybe from third grade from second
grade the real kind of foundational
skills that we find to be important so
that they can enter fourth grade really
confident and and knowledgeable to be
successful in their fourth grade math
class
i'm going to show you just a few
screenshots of how you get to the get
ready for grade level courses
first thing you want to do is get onto
our website khan academy.org
here you can either log in or if you
don't have a khan academy account yet
you can sign up and it's pretty easy you
can do so with your google account for
instance or you can create a new
username and password
once you're in the khan academy site and
we're looking at this from kind of a
student perspective so this is what your
child might see
they can on the top left corner go to
courses
and
from there click that drop down and you
can see on the bottom right of my
slide here there's going to be a list of
the entire khan academy library and this
math get ready courses that'll have a
green new button to let you know
will show up and then just pick the
grade level that your child will be
entering in the fall you can do it
another way you can get to the get ready
for grade level courses is just by
typing in or clicking on this link
directly and we'll be making these
slides available to after the webinar
once you click into a get ready course
you're going to see a pop-up that says
show what you know
and there's going to be an option to
start a course challenge now we
recommend that students or children
start with the course challenge because
it's going to take them through a set of
skills where they can demonstrate what
they know and what they might to just
brush up on a little bit
and that course challenge
can also guide students on what they
should be doing or what they might want
to focus their time on again what they
might want to brush up on after taking
the course challenge
and as your children are working through
the get ready course
you and they can track how they're doing
by the number of mastery points that
they earn on the top left hand corner
we suggest usage of increasing progress
towards mastery by five to ten
percentage points each week
as you see right here on the screenshot
this student has made about 20 of
progress through the entire get ready
for fifth grade course
we imagine five to ten percentage points
each week camp con is
10 weeks by the end of 10 weeks if your
child has followed the weekly suggestion
they hopefully will be at 100 completion
or getting pretty close to it
all right we'll deliver a lot of
information pretty quickly here
and we'll just run down some faq some
questions that we've also heard from
from parents so one we hear
a question is camp
con right for my child
as we mentioned before camp con is a
free resource for students entering
grades three through 12
and it's a way to brush up our math and
it's also a way to look for fun and
motivational activities throughout the
summer we're
hoping it's a low lift and we're also
hoping it's flexible so if parents want
to join us for
the whole 10 weeks great if they want to
join us for five weeks or three weeks
that's totally fine too
what age is camp con 4
we are targeting camp con for learners
and they're in grades 3 through 12
because that's where our get ready for
grade level courses are in math
now younger students can also join us
for camp con kids beginning july 6th
these are for
students who are ages 2 through 7. again
younger kids who might want to have that
exposure to learning activities and fun
activities this summer
third question we've heard is what i
have to do to sign up and participate
really signing up for a khan academy is
most of what you need to do
as a parent now your child will get
these
weekly notifications with suggestions
and recommendations once they do any
work on our our get ready courses
and then speaking of get ready courses
the last question is which get ready
course should my child sign up for
we would suggest that
children start with a grade level that
they're entering
now if um your
child is exceptional at math or is um
really doing some advanced math they
might go to a higher grade
uh or similarly if they are struggling a
little bit math we might recommend going
into a lower grade but
broadly generally speaking we would say
the grade level
course that they should start with on
the get ready is the one that will be
entering in the fall
all right so we've done a few faqs
and so now we're going to turn it over
to questions
and this is where i'm going to talk with
patty a little bit and she's going to
share some of the questions hopefully
we'll be able to answer them here
awesome thank you so much roy for
sharing that wonderful information with
us and just again my name is patty here
i get the pleasure to be on
the district partnerships team with roy
um and so as part of the information
that roy just shared with us we also
want to make sure we're grabbing any of
the questions you might have
and so throughout the question
area i also saw
people were asking where can i get the
slides where can i look at
the handout and potentially you know is
this a webinar that's going to be
recorded and shared with us so the
answer to all those is yes you will
receive
both the deck so slide deck or handout
and you'll also receive a recording of
the webinar via email after
our session and then if you are in your
go to webinar screen there should be a
little tab that says handouts and that
tab will have a pdf called campcon
article webinar so if you click on that
you'll then be able to see all the
information that roy shared as well
so this would be a great time if you
want to add some pressing questions that
came up for you i i can see a lot of
folks are adding questions as well and
we're going to start out with one that i
also noticed was pretty common roy
and it's specifically coming to us from
carrie
and carrie has actually already started
using kempcon this week
and so she's using it with her two
kiddos one of them is in fifth grade
seventh grade and they're enjoying it
and they're wondering a little bit about
what the page should be for a student to
kind of move through the content so
she's saying you know she wasn't really
sure what time to aim for is there a
recommendation or a time that students
should spend weekly on camp con
yeah great question carrie thanks for
getting started on the get ready courses
and hope your girls are enjoying the
courses
we recommend probably about two or three
hours per week on
um to get ready for grade level courses
now you can split those out you know
an hour a day for two days or you can
say you know i'm gonna do 30 minutes or
45 minutes a day for you know four or
five days that that's totally up to you
again we want this to be as flexible as
possible given your schedules and then
in addition to the hours spent per week
we also recommend that students make
about five to ten percentage point
increase in their mastery progress
awesome thank you i think that will be
really helpful for parents as they're
nudging and encouraging students to to
work through their get ready for grade
level courses so a little bit more on
the logistics roy just to make sure
parents are really clear and anyone
who's joining us on the line
um suture wants to know is camp con
limited to math
yeah
great question so camp con the um
the work that students will be going
through is limited to the get ready for
grade level courses which are in math
at the same time
we're hoping that camp con is more than
just math we're hoping it's an
opportunity for students to build
confidence it's an opportunity students
to have a little bit of fun because it
is summer so we're going to be infusing
those suggestions for progressing in
math on those get ready for grade level
courses along with say some reflection
prompts i ask students to really think
about you know how do i learn best what
do i do when i find myself struggling
with learning something how do i feel
when i
you know finally do learn something
that's really challenging so some of
those learning reflections and prompts
that's going to build their confidence
and awareness as a learner and then also
some fun activities like getting outside
and going on nature walks or doing
virtual tours
through museums that are offering these
great opportunities or looking through
some of our content like pixar in a box
or imagineering in the box that's really
about creativity
thank you for sharing that yeah i think
it's great to make sure there's a
holistic kind of set of opportunities
for students
awesome so the next question comes to us
from jeffrey and jeffrey wants to get
super clear do parents or students pick
the course level
and
can they switch if needed
great question jeffrey
students will initially pick the course
level so we would ask that parents are
just sitting alongside their child as
they pick the course level
we do recommend that students at least
start with a grade level that they're
going to be entering in the fall and
your second question they can always
switch if they want they can always
click into other classes and they'll get
ready for grade level courses depending
on whether they find the material too
challenging or too easy
great i think that flexibility is key
for students and for parents as well
um so let's switch um the view a little
bit and think more about the student
themselves who's going to be working on
this content and so
when we think about
the design of the
courses
are they
you know getting students to catch up on
their current grade level and this
question is specifically from yin ju so
just want to be clear gender we're
answering your question um are the get
ready classes designed to help students
catch up to their career level or
can they also be used for advanced
learners and how could they be used for
advanced learners
yep yeah another great question
the
the creation of the get ready courses
was more to get students caught up so
more to your first question we want to
make sure again that if you do the get
ready for
um let's say fifth grade course you're
going to enter fifth grade ready to
learn the fifth grade math
or
advanced learners will they be good
i think to get ready courses could
potentially be
good courses for advanced learners too
and i'm thinking particularly for you
know if we have some middle school
students middle school kind of
mathematicians who are really kind of
chopping in the bit to know a little bit
about high school math or to think you
know i wonder how well i would do in
algebra they could take those high
school level courses just to get a sense
of what they would need to be successful
in those courses so the short answer is
for advanced learners i would recommend
even going on to grade levels above
where the student is going to be
entering in the fall
that's great that's a great suggestion
and as we're thinking about students
potentially looking or reviewing content
and potentially getting stuck right we
know that that happens and that's okay
when you're learning math
so how could uh kids seek help and this
is a question from napor
who wants to know um or references that
you mentioned roy that there's going to
be an option to seek guidance so how
could students get help
yep great question to poor in each of
our exercises in khan academy there are
videos
students can watch that gives them kind
of a
a teaching of what the concept is and in
addition there are hints that will give
students kind of step by step how you
solve this
problem
we always recommend that students watch
the video first because that's broadly
just about the concept and we've also
seen some students just watch the videos
before they even start on their problems
in addition to the videos every student
is really stuck they can always just
click the hint under each question and
the hint will be a step-by-step solving
of that particular question the student
is seeing
and we think this is a great way for
students to
you know again take a little bit of
ownership or more ownership in in their
learning and also we hope this is a way
where a student isn't constantly going
to be asking you the parent for for help
every time they might be stuck
that's really that's really helpful and
um a similar question from deanna
to related to that right like do parents
need to be hands-on helping or is it
fairly simple for kids to navigate on
their own so maybe just sharing a little
bit more about how kids can navigate on
their own
yeah
great question the question of whether
or how much parents should be hands-on
we leave it totally up to the parent
again we want camp con and our courses
to be pretty flexible and really to
promote kind of self-student self-driven
learning but for from the student so for
a student um when they get on the khan
academy we do recommend starting with
that course challenge and then the
exercises we always recommend that
students kind of follow a blue button so
there's kind of a blue start button or a
blue continue button and once you click
on those then students will get underway
under exercises and then once in their
exercises they can start looking at
those videos and viewing those hints and
then if they're stuck we can recommend
that you know they ask maybe an older
sibling or they ask another adult in in
the um in their household and then
eventually um
we we might ask that they reach out to
the parent
i think that's that's great scaffolding
i think very similar to the way teachers
have the three before me rule sometimes
in the classroom so maybe parents
caregivers out there can do the three
before me and uh the first one can
definitely be khan and the resources
that you mentioned roy
um similar to that i think as part of uh
being a parent talasi asks
how do we as parents see the progress of
our students and what they're learning
yep
another great question
a couple ways you can do this one is to
just have the student have the child
show you what they're working on
and how much progress they're making
another way and we're going to send this
in an upcoming email is to join your
student account
and
watch
not watch i guess and see their progress
on
the get ready for grade level course so
this is going to require
um
the parent to add the child's account
and then for the child to approve the
parent so there's going to be a little
bit of back and forth so that this
parent can see
what the child is working on and how
they're doing on it
and we're going to send those
instructions out in an upcoming email
great that'll be really really helpful
we have another question from kimberly
asking can my child use their district
khan academy account or do they have to
create a new student account
yeah
students can use existing accounts and
just you know go and start working on
their get ready course they don't need
to create a new account for camp con
that's great that's very helpful um we
have now a question from april
and we probably have room for a couple
more so for sure please keep asking your
questions this is from april
who says do you have any example of the
fun activities that go in conjunction
with the get ready courses who makes the
clickable videos
yeah great question so
like i mentioned the fun activities will
be coming some from our content library
so i mentioned our you know pixar in a
box or imagineering in a box and those
are kind of videos and activities that
are meant to spark
children's imagination we also have
content from our growth mindset library
for instance which is really meant to
explain the brain science behind getting
smarter so we see those as more kind of
motivational content so that's one side
of that of the fun and motivational
activities they're going to come from us
another part of the answer is from our
partner organizations so we partner will
be partnering with schools like the um
like wide open schools that have great
suggestions and activities on things
families can do outdoors
during the summer for instance taking a
nature walk
um we'll work with other organizations
about virtual tours that uh students can
take during the summer so those are just
some examples of what we'll be including
in the um fun activity section of our
weekly
emails
that's really helpful
um great we have another question from
louise
uh louise says i'm a grandma helping my
grandson we're at different locations
any suggestions
thanks louise and thanks for thinking
about your grandson even though he may
not be right there with you
now our suggestion is to pass along the
article that's in this webinar that
handout
and there'll be some directions there
for getting started or to have them get
on khan academy and there are
links to sites specifically the camp con
details
that a student any student once they get
on the website they'll have directions
there and then they can get started just
by following directions on their site
wonderful
and then i think this will be our last
question roy um which came up a little
bit uh with some other participants so
this is specifically from lim and a
couple others i would like to know how
the get ready courses are different than
the other grade level courses you
already have out there
yep
thanks for that question lim i apologize
for not being clear about this during
the webinar the get ready courses let's
say
and are get ready for fifth grade
course level it's actually pulling from
our math courses our regular grade level
courses in fourth grade in third grade
and second grade so the get ready for
fifth grade course is actually
containing
skills
and content from grade levels below
fifth grade that are met or that have
been identified as the most crucial most
important things to know before you
start fifth grade
so in other words the difference between
the get ready for fifth grade uh course
content and the fifth grade
course content is the fifth grade course
content is going to be what your child
learns in the fall
the get ready for fifth grade course
content is going to be the content
that's going to prepare your child to be
successful to learn fifth grade math in
the fall
so i hope that distinction was helpful
yeah i think that will be really helpful
to a lot of folks and i think roy
that'll be it for our questions so if
you want to wrap us up
great
thanks very much again for all of your
time
um i'm going to
um we will send out these slides and in
addition um please visit our website and
you will get an email with the resources
here and a survey link so please fill
out the survey link that will help us to
improve our webinars and also continue
to hear from you all
thanks very much